Hello.
Car.
I thought I was okay yesterday.
Then I went out last night.
I had like worked all day.
Then I went out last night and I went to a restaurant and I got potatoes.
And my stomach was like, no.
I was like, no!
All I did was eat potatoes.
Okay, wait, and corn soup.
And then I woke up.
I was like, oh gosh, my tummy is still not feeling so good.
And...
I drank tomato, no, sorry, veggie juice.
It's more than tomatoes.
It's a veggie juice.
And...
My tummy was just like, oh, are you dying?
Oh, gosh.
The feeling after a food coma, I wish it was that.
I wish it was a food coma.
Guys, I have a food poisoning.
I've had it for a couple of days.
But I thought yesterday I was okay.
I was like, all right.
I've had nothing.
I was like, I've gone the whole day.
I'm feeling mostly okay.
Man.
Yogurt can help?
Wait, really?
Wait, can it actually?
The cursed Japan trip.
This trip, I've gotten sick so many times.
I think I need to go to the boo-spital when I go home.
Because I'm like, I need a checkup.
I'm like, am I okay?
Why do I keep getting sick?
The boo-spital?
Yeah, it's the hospital but for ghosts.
You know?
Good bacteria for the stomach.
Probiotics.
I wonder if I could go get like a Yakult.
Okay.
My poison was too weak.
The ghost-spital?
No, no.
The boo-spital.
Please understand.
I don't make the rules.
You can get gummy probiotics.
Also, I thought maybe I was just like...
I was like, oh my gosh.
Oh, thanks really.
Sorry you've been sick.
Sending you some extra energy.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I thought also I was just like...
When the night that I got the food poisoning, I was just...
I had McDonalds which is like just the most pathetic thing I think ever in the world.
To get food poisoning from McDonalds.
But I also took like an iron gummy supplement.
And it's like supposed to be a super strong supplement.
So I was like, oh, okay.
Cool.
Maybe...
I was like, I don't know if it's a McDonalds or if it's...
My...
My... my... my spirit is just rejecting the iron.
Your system disagreeing with the amount of grease?
I don't eat so much, so it's like...
Yeah...
But sorry.
Sorry to be complaining.
I don't mean to complain this whole time.
But it is going to be a shorter stream.
Just to guys give you some context.
This is why...
It's a shorter stream.
Just to give some context, you know?
But yeah!
Welcome everybody to this game called Love Ghosty!
I thought it was pretty cute.
I was like, this is... I mean, it's about a ghost.
And then that's me.
So...
Listen to the music, it's so cute.
I remember seeing the trailers for this a while ago.
Didn't think I'd be awake for this.
Good morning!
Top right is my oshi.
Sorry.
I went out last night, like I said.
I did some karaoke thinking that I was okay.
Until I got there and I was like, I'm not okay.
But...
I screamed a little bit.
Now my voice is kind of...
Kind of gone.
Kind of look like Animal Crossing characters.
Yeah, a little bit.
But...
Yeah, you like go around and you like match these characters.
Look at them.
Oh, I'm blocking them.
It looks like the polar bears fallen in love with me.
Actually, the spotlight is on me.
Oh my gosh, I'm not the matchmaker.
I'm the matchee.
Oh my gosh.
Polar bear.
I didn't even go to the Arctic.
I went to the Antarctic.
Which many people actually confused where you are from.
But I know the real truth.
I know.
From Zanzibar land.
I'm going to Alaska, baby.
But yeah, so I just want to play it.
I was listening to a certain Ikenai...
Oh, Ikenai.
I almost read Ikenai borderline.
A certain Ikenai that cover.
I was crying and being nostalgic.
Reminded me how much I love your spirit.
Get it?
Because it goes.
Spirit?
Spirit.
Haruka!
Thanks for the gift card.
Oh yeah, let's play game.
Let's play game.
Hold on.
I make stuff on my computer.
Oh, I was going to say press space but we can just play.
If I have to move around too because...
Oh, see.
I was going to say, hello.
I don't know what to say because of any dialogue or whatever.
Psst!
Hey!
Are you awake?
Oh my god!
Hahaha!
Just kidding!
You're dead!
Why are you going to call me out like that?
This is messed up!
Don't laugh at me being dead!
But the good news is you're a ghost!
Wait, hold on.
There we go.
I died?
Yeah, it's a lot to take in.
I'll give you some time to process it.
Okay, time over.
Okay, now that we're over it, let me introduce myself.
I'm Ghostina.
Oh my gosh, just because we're dead doesn't mean our ghost names have to be so...
ghost-related.
Like, I know I know a ghost of her, but like...
That's different, okay?
I'm Ghostina, and your mentor for the afterlife.
Guess what WE do in the afterlife.
Sentiment phantom.
What'd you say?
I can't hear you over me being a perfect ghost.
I can't...
I can't hear you over me being a perfect...
real ghost.
Yeah, tell her.
Matchmaking!
We do matchmaking in the afterlife.
Contrary to popular belief, we don't just scare people.
Even though that can be pretty fun.
We love watching romances bloom...
Happy to report that I have paid off and received the first $500 worth of my OnlyPhantom commissions.
Only about $600 more to go!
Filling up the tag, aren't you?
Thank you.
Kinky my man.
Stop!
They didn't even... they wrote... they didn't even put their name.
They said me.
No doxxing.
We love watching romances bloom on the battlefield.
And making people happy.
Fun fact.
Did you know ghost-driven romances are 20 times more successful than dating apps?
You guys!
These are the real stats.
These are the real stats, okay?
Oh my gosh, sorry.
I'm watching this guy on TV.
He has a cowboy hat on.
And a denim shirt on with an American flag.
And he is wearing an American flag ascot.
And he's giving makeovers to old Japanese ladies.
Howdy.
Okay, sorry.
We just don't get credit for it.
No!
Because we're done.
I died?
Still not over it, huh?
Anyway.
Welcome to the manor.
Whoa.
What's a wisps gotta do to get a ghostly matchmaking?
Hey.
Hey, hey, hey.
I'll get in line, first of all.
And also, I just...
When I feel like it.
Where is everybody?
Yeah, it's empty.
I turned them all into ghosts?
Ghostina.
Just kidding.
Oh my gosh.
I was gonna say, Ghostina.
You've been busy.
Anyways.
No one lives here.
Don't worry.
That'll change soon.
You better not pair me with a dragoon.
I mean.
It's already...
Anonymous wisp.
Minto.
It's up to you.
Up to you.
Link me up with my crew.
Who's also a wisp.
I believe in you.
This makes sense.
They do ship chat with themselves often.
I'm telling you.
What are you doing for a Scooby snack?
Raggy.
A Scooby snack?
I'll do anything for a Scooby snack.
What can it be a Minto snack?
What would a Minto snack be?
Oh.
Corn.
I put up a sign that says free rent in this definitely not haunted house.
Out in front.
Now before people move in.
Let's begin your training.
Okay.
So this is so opposite of me.
Because I do not want people moving into my maid cafe.
You know.
My training.
Corn soup chips.
Oh.
Yum.
Corn.
Do you guys remember that corn kid?
The key to offering good love advice is that first you must love yourself.
Think you're up to it.
Shut up, Murphy.
I don't want to hear that BS.
That's fake.
I don't want to hear it.
The corn kid.
Yeah.
The kid that was just like, I love corn.
Corn.
And he like went super viral.
And like.
Every time.
Everybody was just like, yeah.
This is corn kid.
I hope that kid's doing well.
People even made songs about him.
Big lump with knobs.
Yeah.
Oh.
I drew all of this myself.
Wow.
We're going to be honest.
Looks kind of shabby.
Well.
I'm not an artist.
I am a ghost.
Yeah.
Who went to art school.
Oh.
Mood.
Anyway.
Residents live their lives and have no idea you're here.
But you can still make a difference.
Yeah.
You can still make a difference.
First we need items.
Meet me in the attic.
Oh.
Okay.
Look at.
Oh my gosh.
When I move.
Oh.
Here.
I hear.
Let me move actually.
Um.
When I move.
There's like a little love trail.
I'm leaking.
Oh my gosh.
I'm leaking ectoplasm.
And it's pink.
It's kind of new.
Oh.
I can zoom in and out.
Okay.
I'm going to use watch to then.
I'm going to go through the house.
Whoa.
Oh my gosh.
There's a bunch of fake people in this house.
Oh!
Oh.
Look at me.
I can go through walls and everything.
What's happening?
Ah!
One second guys.
I'll try it.
I don't need.
I don't see.
I don't know if there's more than.
What I see but.
See you later!
WHAT'S HAPPENING?!
Change the... I saw it...
Oh wait, let me do... let me change the permission.
Sorry guys.
Save.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah, okay.
There we go.
That was crazy.
That's never even happened to me before.
Oh my gosh.
I've never had bots like that before.
Get out of here, bots!
Skynet invasion.
If I have to change it... I'm even gonna change it to 10 minutes.
They'll get bored.
Go away, bots.
Just in case.
Oh my gosh.
Begun!
Minto's first bot attack.
Oh my gosh, you guys saw my first ever bot attack!
Come on!
Plus 5000 social credit.
What does that mean?
Okay, anyway.
We're a ghost.
That's right.
We're meeting a ghost in an attic.
Oh, there's like an apple there.
Okay.
I was here.
Speak.
You know how you mysteriously lose a sock in the laundry?
That was probably a ghost.
The quoting bots from the FNAF stream.
Wait, I don't remember those.
What quoting bots?
We like taking stuff.
When you see something you like, you can take it.
But it costs you an arbitrary ghost action point.
Don't ask why.
Why?
Listen.
Who's been a ghost longer?
Do you know how ghosts work?
I've been a ghost longer, for real.
Hey, first bot attack.
Congratulations.
Thank you!
I don't steal your socks.
That's nasty.
Stop stealing my socks, you stink.
I'm not stealing socks!
I don't care about your socks!
Where were you during the 2024 mental bot attack?
Listen.
Who's been a ghost longer?
Do you know how ghosts work?
We have action points.
It's a ghost thing.
Maybe when you were alive, you had to sleep.
But when you're a ghost, you have action points.
Anyway.
Try grabbing this apple on the ground now.
Apples shouldn't be on the ground anyway.
I'm stealing?
For an action point.
Okay.
I'm stealing.
Enjoy ghost.
Thanks for the 20 gifted.
Nice.
Now that we have an item, there are a couple of things we can do.
One option is to sell it on the ghost... the ghost internet.
Oh my gosh.
That place is scary.
I do not go there.
Say that computer over there.
From there, you can sell items for ghost money.
You guys remember when I tell you that the ghost world is just like the human world?
See?
It's so similar.
She doesn't steal socks.
She steals panties.
Stop guessing correctly.
From there, you can sell items for ghost money.
You can also buy nicer items that you can't find in the manor.
Feel free to take a look.
Whenever you're ready, pick a resident and go to their room for the next lesson.
I'll meet you there.
Oh my gosh.
Joy!
Thanks for the aqua super.
I'm so happy.
Hold to...
Oh, hold shift to sprint.
Oh my gosh.
Look at me go.
I'm interacting.
Oh my gosh.
Not dead it.
The ghostie forums.
Help!
I sold my apple during training.
I got an apple during training and I sold it by accident.
Help!
What do I do?
I don't want to get in trouble.
It's my first day.
It's okay.
Don't worry.
They have backups.
What?
I didn't know you could sell it.
I thought we were supposed to keep it.
You think they wouldn't account for it?
They're ghost selling their apple in training.
I sold mine.
I got money for it.
Help!
Thanks for the 20 gifted.
I'm going to sell my apple.
Yippee!
Wow.
It sold so fast.
And was I not supposed to sell it?
Send emails.
Earn money.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Four doubloons.
Who do we want to go bother of these fake residents?
We have cat.
We have bunny.
Who is employee of the month?
Do I see so?
Hold on.
Yes.
Employee of the month.
What did he do?
We have this crow and a bear.
Cardboard car.
He's got a...
Yeah.
He's got...
He's got a...
A car bed.
Bot attack.
I hear it's amazing when the famous purple stuffed worm in Flapjaw's space with the dirty fork does the raw blink on Harakiri Rock.
I need scissors 61.
The cat is cute.
Okay.
I'm going to go with the cat.
Oh, you picked person.
It's not a person.
It's a cat.
Good choice.
Okay.
Now we just need that...
You sold the apple?
Well, I guess we'll have to continue with this.
It's a training apple I keep for emergencies.
I'm sure you know what else ghost can do with apples.
It's a cat.
Well, that's why you possess people and eat their food.
And then get food poisoning for it.
We still have butts!
But they're mostly for sitting.
Oh, I have a butt.
Anyways...
We can give things to residents.
Yeah!
But we just...
But we can't just say this gift was from a ghost in your house that you can't see but is actively watching you right now.
Trust me.
I did that.
Oh my gosh, speaking of butts, you guys, I heard something.
And I'm bestowing this knowledge to you.
I heard that millennials... I don't know if it was just millennials.
I think I heard it about millennials, though.
But that millennials are not getting enough fiber.
And I think probably, I'm like, oh my gosh.
Food poisoning.
I'm making this food poisoning thing my whole personality.
But they're not getting enough fiber.
And...
But I've heard actually...
I heard actually that like people are getting colon cancer because they're not getting enough fiber.
Which if that's true, that's crazy.
And you guys need to have fiber.
Eat...
prunes?
Raisins.
Eat raisins and prunes.
Everybody.
My veggie drink that I'm drinking right now has lots of fiber.
Fiber wipe off.
So true.
So eat your fiber everybody, okay?
Eat your fiber.
Eat your fiber and make sure that your butt is healthy.
Fiber glass.
I think, okay.
Just a suggestion.
Remove the glass part.
I think you're good.
It's just a suggestion though.
Yeah.
Everybody eat your fiber.
Okay.
Worst 30 years ever.
I really thought I'd win them over.
So when you leave a gift, say it's from someone else in the house.
Stay safe.
Keep pooping.
So true.
Gifting requires action points.
My life changed ever since I got more fiber.
Wifi is a thing of the past.
Yeah.
Fiber internet.
Fiber intake.
Fiber wipe off.
You need all kinds of fiber.
Except the glass.
You'll be able to make pairs of residents closer with your gifts.
Okay.
Try gifting the apple in this spot and pick which resident you want to gift it from.
I'm gifting my...
Wait.
This is worth six coins.
Oh, dang it.
I can't leave.
I was going to go sell it.
It's from Burbson Burbson.
Burbson or Bunson?
Oh, it's from Bunson.
Gift.
Aww, they're a cute couple.
Look at you.
I guess you're a supernatural.
They're not getting colon cancer because of a lack of fiber, but because they can't stop shoving things into places they're not supposed to.
Thanks, Dr. ButtsMD.
I've been waiting on that joke.
I've been dying to tell you the whole time.
I remember.
Residents all have different things they like.
The better the gift, the better the effect on their relationships.
Alright.
Looks like you have two actions left for the day.
Let me show you what else you can do.
Okay.
The chore board.
Oh my gosh.
Thankfully, every resident who ends up living here agrees to work together to make this house better.
They put up this...
So it's not me that has to do stuff.
They put up this handy chore board here.
Actually, I put it up.
But it's not like I can tell them that.
Why would you make them do chores?
Do you want to do them instead?
Besides, it's good for them.
You'll see.
From here you can assign residents to chores to do at the end of the day.
Oh.
Let's try it out.
Every day there are three types of chores.
Dates?
I love that dates are a chore.
This is so real.
That's ghost thinking.
So true.
Less cupid and more manager.
No.
Dates, self care, and house helper.
I think only one of those should be a chore.
Each of these costs ghost action points.
So only assign the ones you want.
Plus some residents will like certain chores more than others.
Introvert stuff.
Dates are a chore.
It's true though.
I believe.
Select a slot on a chore to learn more about it and assign a resident.
Go to the beach.
Outdoorsy.
Bright.
Listen to music.
That's my favorite.
Oh gosh.
I have to listen to music.
Let's do it.
I like person.
Musical.
Classic.
Nice.
You can assign another chore if you're ready to move on.
Finalize your assignments with the assign button.
I'm gonna also cook dinner.
Ambitious.
Complex.
Messy.
I think Burbson can handle this.
Go to the beach.
Oh, not enough.
Wait, what do you mean I have...
Oh, that's my money.
Okay, yeah.
Aside.
And that's how a typical day would go.
Normally, you'll get to see how the date between the two residents goes.
But that one wasn't worth watching.
Wait, I don't get it.
Yeah, that's exactly what they sound like.
Anyways, you have a limited number of ghost action points per day.
So keep that in mind when deciding what to do.
As residents care more for each other, you'll be able to watch their relationship grow.
With enough love, there will be a new development in the relationship that you can unlock and watch.
I feel very voyeuristic right now.
And now you've completely completed your training.
Congrats!
You are now a certified ghost.
What does that even mean?
Listen, be proud.
That's a very rough process.
You had to die for it.
But here's your reward.
Certificate for being a ghost!
I'm
so happy!
Oh my gosh.
You just moved from the voyeur hotel.
I'm just kidding.
Oh, look here.
We've got tons of resident applications during your training.
As your real reward, you get to choose the first four residents.
Wait, what about Person?
No, no, I want Person to stay.
I've grown attached.
Please let Person stay.
I get to choose the first four residents.
But Person!
Person!
Thanks for the super giant!
Is that a lizard?
Wait, that's a dragon?
What the heck?
Oh my god, frog.
Okay, hold on.
Okay, alright.
We're gonna do...
We're gonna...
Wow.
Okay, hold on.
We're gonna do the frog.
We're gonna do lizard.
We're gonna do the robot.
And we're gonna do a...
Tiger.
Frog.
This one... Ami is cute though.
I need more space for all my experiments!
Please pick me!
Actually wait, Ami's kinda cute.
So is Mina.
I need my own space.
I can live just fine on my own!
Had my heart broken.
Everything reminds me of her.
So here I am.
Oh my gosh, Gerard.
I've always lived on my own because honestly, you're my best roommate!
But I should probably talk to other people!
House tiger?
That's what I'm saying!
Prepare the tiger and robot for taiga- Taiga Saiba!
Okay, you're so right.
Okay, continue.
Confirm.
Well, we all have ghost stuff to do.
So I'm gonna leave you here to do what you want in the manor.
All four residents will be moving in tomorrow.
So try your best.
I'll check in on you after three days.
Welcome to your afterlife!
See you later!
Day...
Two...
Day two...
Day one?
A resident is arriving!
Oh my gosh!
What's happening?
Oh...
He's so competent!
It's Apollo!
A resident is arriving!
Royalty is here.
Who is this?
A frog!
Kissing this frog will turn into a dashing prince.
Oh my gosh.
A talent!
A resident is arriving!
Oh my gosh.
Robot.
Oh no.
Guys, I like robots.
Oh my gosh, robot is taking...
It's Beeple!
Lost, welcome to membership, thank you!
A resident is arriving.
Me, for real, for real.
It's...
Chamble?
Camel?
But they're a lizard, but their name is...
Camel.
Camille?
Oh...
Oh, Camille!
Okay, okay, okay, like chameleon.
Oh,
I think the horns...
Oh wait, I think they're kind of I think the horns and the wings are not real.
Wait, I just realized this.
I think they're cosplaying like...
Solid Snake.
Oh my gosh, here we go.
Look at them!
Oh my gosh, they're in their houses.
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, what's that?
Oh, I can steal their stuff!
Okay, we gotta pair these guys.
Oh.
Log report number one.
Moved into a new biome today.
Excited to observe and perhaps even find a new companion.
To mimic my surroundings, henceforth my log reports shall be in the form of a diary entry.
I'm already learning so much.
The music is so cute, so relaxing.
Check the computer.
Dead it.
No, that is not Solid Snake.
How do I know who I want to matchmake?
OMG, everyone is so cute, but I don't want to accidentally commit the wrong pair of residents.
How do I decide... oh, how did you decide who to ship?
Oh, you can totally ship them around with each other and figure out who you want to focus on.
How did you know that?
Because I totally ship them around with each other.
OMG, did they hate each other when you did that?
It takes some time to fully...
Nah, it takes some time to fully develop their feelings.
So you can experiment with couples before they fully commit.
You reply deleted my user!
Oh.
Thumbs down, thumbs down, thumbs down, thumbs down.
Point and laugh at the cosplayer.
Oh.
Is the dragon also a cosplayer?
What are you talking about?
Help, I skipped the tutorial!
I skipped the tutorial and now I don't know what to do!
Thumbs down, thumbs down, thumbs down.
CLDR, you died, now you're a ghost.
I died?
Oh buddy, you missed some good jokes.
Maybe you shouldn't have skipped it.
You're a matchmaker and your goal is to create cute couples.
You have a limited number of action points per day that can be used for stealing items, gifting, or assigning residents to the chore board.
Different chores have different goals.
Some increase relationship levels and some increase resident happiness.
Remember, residents have preference for certain items and chores.
You can also buy and sell items on Beepbay.
Oh, sorry, Eepbay.
Oh, and Ghostina, best mentor ever, will check on you in three days.
Tutorial?
They told me it was training.
I knew it!
Conspiracy theory?
I can sell some of this stuff.
We know!
Okay, let's see.
Oh, they all have little diaries and stuff too.
I can take all this stuff.
Okay, hold on.
Let's read.
Oh my gosh, he's so sporty.
But he had that, he's also a nerd.
He had that space book, right?
Oh!
Wait, what'd you say, Evan?
Starting the search for a new job!
Wish me luck, Boris, and thanks for all the love and encouragement you give us every day.
Evan, good luck!
You got this.
He's staring right at me.
I think he knows I'm here.
Dear diary, I'm so excited to be here.
Everyone here looks like they're full of potential.
Potential to be a friend.
He's already friend-zoning everybody.
Boo!
What's this?
We got no mail.
It literally just was a puff of smoke.
Dear diary, no doorman.
No bellboy.
No maid.
No!
I'm right here!
I don't like this reply feature.
Stop!
No maid.
No chauffeur.
This simply won't do.
I suppose I shall take the reins and show everybody everyone how to truly live life.
Dear diary...
Oh, what is this information?
Ah!
Interesting.
They love the cosplay!
Hiding underneath their creations.
What a nerd.
Beep.
Beepo.
Beepo is gonna go hard, okay.
Okay.
Dear diary.
New places.
New faces.
Eep!
It's everything I feared it would be.
Hopefully, no one will notice me.
Nerd.
You're a nerd.
Camel.
What is if I interact with this?
Oh, fancy backpack.
Oh, I could sell it!
Oh, this one is for sunscreen, books, and tickets.
Okay.
Alright, guys.
This one is for pretending you have books.
But it's all snacks.
Alright, time to start giving things and taking things.
What do you think...
Okay, hold on.
I think...
I think they would want something...
Um...
What would tiger or robot want?
Yeah, I don't know if these rooms have doors.
They're just there.
You know, don't worry about it.
The tiger might want an apple.
Because he's fit!
True.
Okay, we're gonna steal this one then.
Lazy?
Unusual.
Wait, why are the...
Oh, last place pair.
The worst pair ever!
You guys, we can't... This is a pair!
This is not a good quality gift.
This is bad.
This is bad, bad, bad.
Oh, check eBay.
Oh, I can buy stuff, can't I?
I only have four bucks though.
Four ghost dollars.
The tiger might want an apple is not the word I was expecting.
Ambitious nerdy!
How is a trophy nerdy?
This is best on it.
This is kinda cute.
None of these are great quality gifts.
Oh, this is...
A unicycle!
Okay, this one is probably...
Active, adventurous, ambitious.
Okay, hold on.
What was the tiger's tags?
What are you about?
Loves to see everyone live their life.
Oh, their best life.
Somehow he's also everyone's best friend.
Okay, we're gonna give him a unicycle.
His tags!
That's what they're called!
My head is blocking it!
It's the tags!
It's the tags, I promise!
I'm not just making this up!
Okay.
Steal!
Nice, okay.
We're gonna give this to you.
It's from Beep.
It's from Beeple.
Oh!
Oh my gosh, our first gift!
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh...
Beeple!
Beep...
Beeple loves...
Oh my gosh!
Discovered tag!
Feel their talk in the common room.
Beeple!
It's so good to see you!
Thank you, Apollo.
I wanted you to know...
I've really been enjoying my time with you.
Does that mean we're friends?
It means we're best friends.
I love spending time with you!
Best friends?
Don't stop friendzoning, Beeple, please!
Yup, you're the best, Beeple.
Wasn't ready for what?
I have to go now.
I'm sorry.
Goodbye!
But wait, before I go...
I also want you to know...
I all enjoy spending time with you too.
I love Beeple.
So please remember that.
Uh...
Okay.
Watch your first relationship talk!
Beeple, are you okay?
Was it too much for you?
Okay, let's see what the chores are.
If we could hook up...
If these two would hook up, would their child be...
Tigatron from Beasties?
Do a paint kit at home.
Compliment someone.
That's a chore?
Water all the plants.
Oh, check Beeple's diary.
Does it work?
I think it'll light up though, right?
Yeah, I think it's per day.
It seems.
Oh, okay, so...
Q, this is the end of the day.
Sorry, you guys are kind of blocking it, but...
Um...
Wait...
Oh, oh my gosh!
This scared me.
Why are you hiding in your own room?
Um...
Okay, let's do some chores.
We have two activity points left.
Vento?
Thanks for the gift, dude.
Well, dude...
Oh, it's only one.
Okay, perfect.
And then...
House helper.
Camel.
Okie dokie.
I think that's it.
Alright, end the day.
Psst!
Ghostina.
Gondolas.
I got you some tickets to watch today's Totally Not A Date.
We ghosties like to watch residents go on these.
Damn!
Thank you!
They can be full of fun, cute romance!
Or full of awkwardness.
Oh no, oh no, you guys, it might be awkward.
Oh no, I might get some second hand embarrassment.
Oh no.
Some residents might even have super special reactions to dates that speak particularly to them.
Based on how well the dates go, the greater the impact of the relationship.
Let's see how you did for your first Totally Not A Date assignment.
See you tonight for the premiere!
Oh no, guys, it might be cringe.
Later that day...
Oh my gosh!
Everybody's here for the premiere!
What the heck?
That's me in the audience.
I guess we're supposed to use this kit to paint by numbers.
Oh, wait, that was Beeple, sorry.
I thought we were supposed to paint by colors.
It's a bunch of pervs in here.
Yeah, everybody's watching!
Oh my gosh, this is so embarrassing!
Is this how real dates are?
Everybody's just watching your date?
All the ghosts?
You guys, I will say...
I have never watched somebody's date.
Actually, that's a lie.
There was that one couple that was at that restaurant.
They did not look happy.
I was definitely paying more attention to them than the seafood.
Well, yes, but each number has a color associated with it.
Wait, how long has it been this way?
No, it's just for this.
I have so many things to recolor!
This changes everything!
No, no, no, watch.
My mint ghost could never be cringe ever.
I refuse to believe that.
Chat, you are all very rude.
Does the basketball ass count?
Oh, that's not a date though.
Oh, I guess it...
Stop
it.
It doesn't feel like it counts.
Okay, they are painting.
Okay, I did it.
Zonko, welcome to Mambo Chef.
Thank you.
You sure did.
This was a lot of fun.
Thanks for calming me down, people.
Anytime, Apollo.
Woo!
They were cheering.
They got like a standing ovation.
Holy cow.
Date was good.
If I ever get another date, you can come along, mint.
Um...
Hmm...
The house helper task was okay.
Camel's relationship with all other residents slightly increased.
Nobody likes frog burp.
Okay.
This is actual crickets.
Good.
Oh my gosh, it's one of these thingies!
The tatamatoms!
Musical note toy.
Sounds silly, but trust me.
Trust me, bro.
What's going on Undeadit?
Gifting.
How do I know if a gift is good?
Are there bad gifts?
Every gift boosts happiness slash romance.
I really like a gift.
You can see a ton of hearts slash emojis fly out of them faster.
That was...
They're hanging out.
You guys.
Without me prompting them.
They're in...
the...
Oh my gosh, sorry.
I was like, what's going on?
They're hanging out.
Dear Dairon.
I had so much fun on an expedition with Apollo yesterday that I forgot to take field notes.
Maybe those memories will be just for me then.
So cute!
Dear Dairon.
Did I upset Beepo by calling them my best friend?
I'm not sure what's going on.
Uh oh.
The Apollo expedition.
APOLLO EXPEDITION!
Shut up.
The Apollo Expedition, you guys.
This might be the most perfect match ever.
This might be the most perfect...
Wait!
Beepo's charging.
What the heck is this?
Architecture shapes.
Why are we gifting baby toys?
Aren't these adults?
Oh!
I think the frog would like the mirror, right?
Oh no.
Frog did not have an interesting enough day to write in the diary.
Neither did camel.
Uh oh.
Okay.
Where did Beepo plug in?
Hey, chill out.
Okay, chill out!
What is this, too?
Oh.
This seems a little too sensitive of a gift, I think.
Hold on.
We were reading dead it.
I got distracted.
Um...
You'll also see in your information menu if you unlocked a new tag if it's something they really liked.
Dang!
We really hit it on the mark then with Apollo.
Higher quality items are also more effective than lower quality ones.
Oh well.
Who doesn't like gifts?
I mean, I like free gifts, but if someone left a skeleton in my room, I'd hesitate at least a little.
We got a toaster?
Okay.
I don't think that frog and camel are a good match, but we'll start matching them.
It might work.
Right?
Fancy.
Fashionable.
We need frog to be happy, too.
It's from...
Camel.
Yeah.
This appeared out of nowhere.
Ooh!
They love the gift.
Look at the membership!
Fancy!
And fashionable.
Look at this!
Look at the hearts!
Wait, the hearts are really sparking, you guys.
I think frog and lizard can be a perfect couple.
Fancy.
Camel.
The chameleon I wanted to see.
Oh, um...
Um, hello.
I have been told you specialize in cloth and thread.
Oh, um, yes.
I guess you could say that.
I have a request to make of you.
Oh, like a commission?
Y-yeah, that...
You see, I have an event coming up.
I need only the best fabrics and details.
All eyes will be on me, after all.
So I need it to be nothing less than extravagant.
Oh, dear.
Would you be able to fashion me...
Oh my gosh, wait.
This is just dress-up, darling.
This is just bisque doll, you guys.
Oh, no.
Would you be able to fashion me a lovely robe?
Well, I'm not sure of my style.
Nonsense.
Listen, I don't have time to discuss at the moment.
Make me a lovely robe, and you will be compensated greatly.
Ta-ta!
Oh, gosh.
What kind of robe did he want again?
This is such a huge ask.
Oh, gosh.
I'm sweating again.
Okay, you can do this, camel.
So no lisque doll?
Oh, my gosh.
I'm like, peeping through the floor.
I'm such a creep.
I'm such a creep, I'm such a creep, I'm such a creep.
Look at the bamboo shoe!
Thank you!
Alright, let's see.
What would maybe...
What is this one?
Oh, they're hanging out!
They're talking about vacuum cleaners?
I think...
Okay.
I'm afraid that if we give the toaster to Robot, to Beeple, that they might think of it as another lover.
So maybe the musical instrument.
Steal!
Is it me or does this house not have any doors?
Don't worry!
It's like a doll house, you know?
Oh, okay.
This is the perfect time to gift this.
Beeple's charging.
From Apollo.
They kinda liked it.
They thought it was okay.
Wait, that's it?
I can even take it back?
No way.
Beeple, we didn't like it.
Beeple...
That's our first miss, you guys.
Okay, time to end the date.
Date to summary.
Gifts.
Fancy!
Thank you!
Okie dokie.
Back to the internet.
Did you know that you can watch dates?
Spoopy girl.
Oh my gosh.
The dates are so cute.
I need to talk to someone about them.
OMG, what?
I haven't assigned anyone to a date yet.
Yeah, after you assign them to a date, you'll see how it goes later that day.
OMG, you're missing out.
My favorite so far is the karaoke date!
It was so adorable.
Wait, the karaoke date?
Wait, I did the karaoke date.
It was super awkward.
Well, maybe you need to pick better couples.
I can't believe I missed so much!
Where did my legs go?
You gonna finish Eternal Darkness?
Yeah, I am!
But I'm not home.
Um...
I'm in Japan.
I don't have my GameCube, obviously.
So, um, yeah.
Once I'm back home though, I'll be able to finish it.
Yes, yes, yes.
Oh, there it is!
Okay, so you can't steal...
Why is there a snowman in the kitchen?
Dear diary, I always tell you how I'm feeling.
And I just want to thank you for being there for me.
Keep up the great work.
It doesn't feel right reading a diary entry like that.
Dear diary, I got a filigree mirror from Camel.
This is perfect.
It's going right next to where I keep my favorite crowns.
I knew it was a perfect gift.
Wait, where's the mirror?
Wait, where is it?
Where's the mirror?
Next to the crowns.
Well, where are the crowns?
Doesn't everybody keep a snowman in the kitchen?
Or is it just us Canadians?
Oh, there it is.
Oh my god.
Can I go underneath the house?
No.
I cannot go into the foundation.
Dear diary, I can do this.
I can do this.
Holland didn't really specify what kind of robes he wanted, so I guess I'll have to go with this design.
Okay.
What is this?
A thermos?
Oh, portable speaker!
Oh...
Okay...
And the snowman...
Messy snowman.
Why did somebody build this indoors?
We could...
Okay, we should start selling stuff too, right?
Because then we can buy new stuff.
Like the fancy painting!
Oh my gosh, wait.
Wait!
This is perfect for frog!
What the hell is this?
A basket cube.
But then probably...
Apollo will love this.
We need cash money, you guys.
Someone soiled it!
Why does it have eyes?
I was wondering that too.
How often do you think a fancy painting comes along?
I don't think we can sell enough stuff to buy it, you know?
Okay, let's do some math, everybody.
Ten?
But wait...
It costs interaction points to pick up everything.
Okay, one, ten...
How many do I need?
Forty-one.
Okay.
Ten...
This one...
Was this one expensive?
No.
Ten plus ten...
Twenty!
Plus...
No!
I don't think we'll make enough!
It's so over...
I don't think it's happening...
No!
Okay, well let's give this to...
Wait, but this is fourteen!
Wait!
That'd be...
That would be...
Thirty-four...
Plus four...
Thirty-eight...
I would have to sell everything to get it.
I would have to grab everything and use all my points.
Dang it...
Okay, what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna steal the...
Steal?
I'm gonna place this down here.
It's another action point to place, right?
Oh no, it's not.
Okay, from Beeple.
Oh yes it is.
Just kidding.
Hold on.
Because...
What I also want to do...
Wait, I can do this!
I can sell one thing...
And then I can also...
Have a date happen.
So I'm gonna sell...
Something that is low quality...
But makes a lot of money.
A lot of money.
These are all kind of low quality.
So I don't want to sell the large...
Okay, grab it.
Hold on.
Let's gift this.
Wait, where did he go?
Oh, they're hanging out.
How do you know each other?
Excuse me.
Go away.
Come get your gift.
From Beeple.
Turn around!
Yeah!
Oh my gosh, they're all hanging out.
He loves it!
Basket cube.
Beeple.
Hi, Apollo.
Did you receive my gift?
That was literally me though.
Why are you taking the credit?
Okay, Beeple is kind of a psycho.
That depends.
Was your gift to me a hundred card signed from your best friend, Beeple?
Oh, good.
I was afraid it would be lost in the mail.
So I sent in 99 more.
Just in case.
Oh, okay.
It wasn't the basket cube.
Thanks, I appreciate it.
But next time, I think one card will be enough.
Understood.
By the way, I noticed your have a lot of friends.
Yeah, I guess I do tend to make friends.
Friends?
I can't even say the word.
I'm so antisocial, I can't even say the word.
Friends.
Pretty easily.
One of them.
One of them is an Olympic athlete.
A wrestler, correct?
Yeah, we trained together back in high school.
Why do you ask?
Oh, because I'm going to have to defeat them in wrestling.
Let's go, Beepo.
Wait, what?
Okay, I have to go train.
I'll see you after I defeated them, Apollo.
Bye.
Wait, Beepo, come back!
Let's go.
I kind of love Beepo.
Beepo's got ambition.
Let's assign these two.
Oh, wait.
Definitely... collecting seashells!
Okay, here we go.
For some reason...
All in and camel.
There we go.
Assigned.
Okay, and then we'll take this guy and we're going to sell him.
Yes.
Okay, good.
Beepo gives Yandere vibes, maybe a little.
Sell.
Money, money!
We're going to try!
Okay, sell one thing a day, guys.
This is kind of a good...
Kind of a good...
Maybe...
Formula.
You give one gift.
You sell one thing and you assign one day.
There's all your points.
For the day.
Everybody good?
Everybody happy?
Okay, end the day.
We're maximizing.
We're min-maxing the ghost game.
Seashell collecting?
What's this music?
I hope we're good at this.
You guys, I think this is the...
I don't think this is the good music.
I don't see how we could be bad at this.
Look!
I already found a...
This is a seashell shaped rock.
Well, that's okay.
I found a...
A seashell shaped water bottle?
Why is this even here?
Okay.
This one has got to be a...
Seashell replica by seashell enthusiast society.
This is PP music, you guys.
This music feels so Tomodachi Live.
You're right.
Why would you leave this at the beach?
Oh god.
We're really bad at this?
They're trauma bonding.
Viewed an awkward date for the first time.
The date was okay.
Their relationship increased a little.
Cool.
Ghosted.
So...
How did your first three days go?
Let's see.
I guess that's pretty good for a first timer.
This is the first time you've been dead, right?
No.
How many times have you died?
Just one so far.
Well, you had a great first three days.
The real reward here is your kindness helped blossom love and a happier home.
We have a store.
The more you develop resident relationships and the more resident happiness you bring the more relationships you get.
Thanks for four months crazy person.
No, hold on.
No.
Spring, spring.
Good try.
I couldn't remember the crazy frog.
I couldn't remember it.
Ghosts love to collect and spend these.
And you can unlock lots of cool stuff with them.
And with the cool stuff you can unlock in my store you can take your matchmaking to the next level.
The possibilities are endless.
Until we run out of things in my store.
But even then.
Shut up.
She expects more from someone who's multi-died.
You can matchmake any pair of residents you want.
And every resident has a completely different story based on who they've developed a relationship with.
Now go out there and see what kind of a world you can make.
Nah.
I'll be here if you want to buy anything.
Okay.
Thanks.
Ghost dinner.
Let's see how you did.
I did amazing, I did amazing, I did amazing, I did amazing.
Oh my gosh!
Wait, there's trees?
Gain plus one action to do a total of five things.
Gain hats for Ghosty to wear?
Wait, what is this?
Oh, I need fifty.
There's minigames!
Unlock a mode to redecorate residents' rooms.
A minigame that requires more coins.
Requires actions.
Learn a scary song to interact with residents!
Hats?
Yeah, but I can do a plus one action points, guys.
Change Ghosty's tail!
Ghosty match residents!
Gain an item to temporarily move out a resident?
Oh my gosh.
Ask the vacation ticket to Ipe.
Wow, there's actually a lot.
I want the scary song.
Wait, there's so much.
We only have thirty-five points.
We can only pick one thing.
And the minigame.
Earns more coins!
But cosmetics.
And what's this one?
Earn ten percent more money when selling items or playing minigames.
But hats.
I'm going to do the minigames because I want to see what they are.
Sorry, guys.
Okay.
I want to know what the minigames are.
Now it's time to move on to the next phase.
Super death.
You're going to die again and you'll have a super afterlife.
Oh, just kidding.
You're going to go back to the manor to develop more relationships.
I really like the romances where you're building.
I want to see more.
Plus, I'll visit my shop in another three days.
For the good of romance, the good of joy in the world, and most importantly, the good of my merchandise shop.
Get out there and make some more romances bloom.
Okay.
Day four.
What is this?
OCD.
Ghosties Love Mix 2002.
Okay.
I got a room upgrade.
What's the upgrade?
What's that?
Something sparkly there.
Oh, wait.
He's putting in stuff in his room.
I see.
Yay!
You have eep mail now.
You can write emails to fish...
I mean fish for more ghost monies.
You better...
The better your scam...
The better the payout.
We run scams?
Scamming is bad.
So we're going to be scamming scammers.
I tracked down all these ghosties who send annoying scam emails.
And we're going to scam them back.
This is my forte.
Writing these emails cause ghost action points though.
So keep that in mind.
I'm composing an email.
It's time to write your first email.
You get an email prompt and you have to fill in the words.
Each word has symbol associated with it and the more symbols that match the more your email will make sense.
Which means more money!
It's like leverage.
Who scams the scammers?
Me!
Mint scammed them!
This is actually a game about mint.
Stop!
Stop being so right.
Some words have multiple symbols which means they can match with any of those.
If you want to slow down the words...
you can adjust the speed in the settings.
Good luck out there and happy fishing!
Hi.
It's your...
loyal fan.
And I...
Am making a statue of you!
And I need money to cover...
The unsolicited replica.
Please send money.
You are my last hope.
I'm a professional, clever, Atypical money maker.
Perfect run, baby.
Look, we already got a scammer.
Read it and collect your money.
Oh wow.
I've been looking for more merch for myself.
Perfect!
Thank you, ghosty son.
25!
Holy cow, we don't need to sell that stuff anymore.
Hi.
It's your loyal fan.
Nano, how are you so fast?
I'm making a statue of you and I need money to cover this unsolicited replica.
Please send money.
You are my last hope.
How are you so fast?
I'm making a statue of you and I need money to cover this unsolicited replica.
IX300, thanks for the vibe gift!
Okay, we made a buttload of money just now.
That was awesome.
My residents had an awkward date.
What do I do?
This has never happened to me before.
What's going to happen?
Are they going to hate each other?
I'm freaking out!
Relax.
Take a chill pill.
It's fine.
They still like each other.
They just didn't gain as much affection as they could have.
It's NBD.
Residents like certain dates that are better suited for them than others.
Take it as a learning opportunity.
Get good.
Get good, ghost.
Lololol.
Google forums.
Fake smiley!
Thanks for the vibe gift!
Oh my gosh.
This happened to me the other day.
It's totally okay.
It happens.
It was totally an accident.
I forgot one of my residents doesn't like the outdoors.
It made for a funny date though.
Oh, there was more.
Does anyone else like to hoard items?
I'm afraid I'll need it later so I hold on to everything.
Lol, I sell my items for money.
Nah, you can always find the same item later if you really need it.
I'm so glad I'm not the only one.
Let's go.
What do we have in Ippei anyway?
A gold mirror?
Dreamy painting?
Gacha machine!
Hi, it's your loyal fan.
I'm making a statue of you.
I kinda wanna make more emails.
Emails are so fun.
Actually.
Dear diary.
Okay, now I'm even more confused.
What does my Olympic wrestling friend have to do with Beeple?
What's going on?
I don't know.
Okay, no one else is happy because no one else wrote in their diary.
But Tiger is living his best life.
He is so happy.
What do you think Beeple...
What is that?
A beaker.
That was nerdy.
What do you think that...
What do you think that Beeple would like?
Loves learning about people observing their lives.
Lifestyles.
Science?
So maybe the nerdy?
It's actually a human prince of the frog kingdom.
Wait, what?
Also, why is Camel not happy?
How is...
How is the frog prince...
How is he human?
Wait, so he really is...
Wait, I don't feel...
Wait, what's this?
Welcome to the memories board.
Oh, cute!
You can re -watch any relationships, talks, or dates you've seen.
It's one of the many perks of being a ghost.
Sixty-six?
Have fun re-watching your favorite dates and talks.
Holy cow.
Five?
Cute and sweet.
This is a high sought after item.
Artsy, cute, and musical.
Artsy is probably...
Camel, right?
So we're gonna steal this for Camel.
We're gonna steal this for Camel.
And it's gonna be...
From...
Frogboard.
Turn around.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Oh, what?
You only just minimally like it?
Really?
You just only like it a little bit?
Okay.
Nevermind.
What's this one?
Classic, fancy, outdoorsy.
Why does it only sell for nine, though?
Oh, we have one point left?
So let's write an email.
Hello.
Good news.
I have an exciting...
I have an exciting warning.
I need you to...
Um...
Oh, destroy?
All your...
Oh...
No!
Friends phone numbers!
I messed up.
Please respond and pay ASAP before it's too late.
I need you to destroy.
Your DNA goes hard.
Oh, time sensitive.
Important.
That message was beautiful.
Take my ghost monies.
We have so much money now.
Nice.
Time to end the day.
Okay.
Nice.
I just got here.
What am I watching?
We're a matchmaker!
Is that matcha ice cream?
Ice cream lamp.
Matchas the decor perfectly.
What is this?
Celery!
An avocado!
Thanks!
10 out of 10.
Unfriended everyone.
Tulips in this economy?
I really thought that...
Camel would like the artsiness.
Oh, this is cute.
Rainbow plush.
Brightens those rainy days.
Aww.
Dear diary.
We should all be good friends.
But we gotta remember to be a good friend to ourselves too.
Why is he the only one writing in this diary?
Everybody else hates me!
What's going on?
Okay, I'm gonna write an email.
Did you know that celery is part of the holy trinity in French cooking?
Why doesn't my house look as nice?
All my residents have bare rooms.
How did you do it?
Have you been working on their happiness?
They'll add to their room if they're happier.
Came here to say this.
Yeah, even common rooms will look nicer if there's total happiness in the house.
Oh!
Don't forget you can increase their happiness with self-care chores.
Oh, self-care chores.
Okay.
Volunteer!
I think Beeple would like this.
They're all hanging out.
What other?
What's that?
Visit a coffee shop.
Donate old clothes.
Yeah.
Visit a cage?
Visit a cafe.
Shall we do a date?
Yeah.
We'll do a date with.
With Froggy and Camel.
Yeah, let's do a date.
Yeah, a sign.
We'll do another email, because I'm obsessed with this.
It's so fun.
Okay, hi.
We're conducting a tarot reading for your butt.
Why is this game so obsessed with butts?
Your future.
Please provide your butt.
Celebrating my birthday with a ghost mate.
Phillip, happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Phillip.
This one's for you, Phillip.
Butt!
Please provide your butt and funds for us to help our research.
Help us with life-changing research.
I don't read messages.
I just give money when things sort of make sense.
Oh my gosh, we got so much money.
We got so much money.
Scary painting!
Artsy.
Complex.
Dark.
Ooh, that boombox.
Giant plush is so cute.
Thanks for that, Peach.
Okay, hold on.
I need to do one more thing today.
What should we do?
They're talking about...
Balls?
What is...
The little triangle.
Creative, musical, noisy.
The quality, though, is really high.
What is Camel...
What is Camel like?
I can't tell.
Peach.
Peaches.
Peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches...
I don't know if they like maybe cute and sweet things.
You know what?
Still.
I can't deliver it because I have no points, but we'll deliver it tomorrow.
Try pressing E in that resident window?
E...
Oh, no, wait, oh.
Oh, I see.
Artsy...
What?
It is artsy.
And bright.
Wait.
Wait, I think the uh... hold on one second.
Oh sorry, nevermind.
I got a message and I was like, wow there's so many more people.
Cute!
Okay wait, so this is perfect then.
This is perfect, this is perfect.
The dash is neutral, but they still have that quality a little bit.
I don't have a birthday coming up, but I just wanted to say that you always saying happy birthday brings a smile to my face every time.
It's so cute.
I'm happy, thank you!
Okay, let's end the day.
Later that day...
Oh, it's a date time!
Oh, it won't be awkward.
Get copy?
Where?
What kind?
You guys, I think Froggy is the problem.
Oh god, I don't know.
Nobody told us anything.
How much copy?
Should we get?
As much as we can carry!
You already had copy before this, didn't you?
I wanted to be prepared.
Stop, you're getting beans everywhere.
Good!
More beans, more beans, more coffee!
Coffee for everyone!
Oh, it was an upside down heart.
It was a butt.
The date was okay.
The relationship is increasing a little by a little.
Beeple is so happy.
Beeple care was good.
Beeple loves to care.
Beeple is practical.
Actually, I have coffee too, but I'm worried about drinking it.
I want the coffee.
You guys ever want the coffee taste?
I actually love the taste of coffee.
It's just...
What is this?
Gothic tea set?
Oh my gosh, it's awesome.
What are they doing?
What are you guys doing down here?
Talking by yourselves?
Oh, and it's done!
You're a day early.
I'm impressed.
Yes.
Oh yes, and I'm so excited!
These are the best wizard...
I put on my robe and wizard hat.
These are the best wizard robes I've ever made.
I'm gonna be a real Minto.
I need all the energy I can get for my college classes that are starting tomorrow.
P.S.
Faye's coffee stream win.
Maybe I should order some coffee, huh?
That takes me back.
All in is definitely the problem.
I think so too.
You are decrepit.
So are you for knowing!
Oh my gosh, Joy!
Thank you so much for the 50!
Thank you!
You're decrepit if you know that reference!
Oh my gosh.
I understood that reference.
Oh gosh, guys, we're old.
Uh oh, all in?
All in?
All in, say it's good.
I'm sorry.
What was that?
Wizard robes?
What?
Is?
He's angry!
This!
I'm sorry.
Oh gosh, is this the wrong color?
Is it?
No.
What are these wizard robes?
Do you take me for some kind of a joke?
You expect me to wear these at a royal ceremony where I will be rewarded for my generous deeds?
Well, he actually is mad.
Royal ceremony?
Oh my goodness, I didn't know.
Are you mocking my royal...
You guys, this is not...
The ship, the ship is sunk.
The ship is sunk.
I'm gonna smack the frog.
Are you mocking my royal responsibilities?
No, I'm so sorry.
I just specialize in cosplay and I thought...
Are you mocking my appearance?
My role?
No, no, I just thought that if you came to me then you wanted...
Enough.
I have never been so insulted.
Good day.
No, I...
I said good day.
Oh, camel.
Dumb, dumb camel.
He's a prince.
Why would he even want to cosplay as a wizard?
Dumb.
So dumb.
No!
I hate Froggy now.
That was so sad.
This dude is always writing in his diary.
Nobody else is.
Dear diary, I love that new book smell.
And that old book smell.
And books in general.
I should renew my library cards.
Can we kick him out?
Kick Froggy out.
Froggy...
Froggy out.
Oh, I should have gotten the scary song, you guys.
This is why I should have gotten the scary song.
Relaxed painting.
The tub is hot and the vibes are chill.
Oh, nice.
What else is here?
Why do all the balls have faces on them?
Perfect for whatever it is beach balls are perfect for.
It's of zero quality though.
I like this one.
I like the gothic tea set a lot.
Piggy bank.
Ambitious.
Neat.
Wait!
This one's good.
This one's good for...
Tiger.
How about frog legs for dinner?
But enemies to lovers?
Okay.
Fair?
You make a valid point.
Oh!
This is from Beepo.
Turn around.
Oops.
I'm gonna go get that coffee.
Actually...
No.
I was like...
I want something kind of sweet.
Because I've been drinking this like...
She loves the dictionary!
Because I have been drinking this...
What's it called?
Juice?
Veggie juice?
But I got this...
Croissant.
And it's kind of sweet.
Even though I didn't want it sweet.
But it is kind of sweet, so...
AI chat thinks the frog and camel are...
Individual streamers.
Wait, but what about...
The lamp though?
If she gets it from...
Froggy...
It's gonna be like...
Kind of awkward, right?
If Froggy gifts of...
The lamp?
I love lamp.
I'm confused.
Why is everybody saying I love lamp?
Well, I'll be trying to make a decision.
I will send an email.
See you later.
Bye.
Hello.
We started pre-orders for our...
Chairs.
That...
Wait, was that...
Can...
Can ghost...
Grow ghost hair?
Oh my gosh.
Chairs...
You can eat!
They will be available!
In various flavors!
So please send us money.
To reserve yours...
Now!
Amazing new product!
I never thought about edible chairs.
What a great idea!
You are so welcome, everybody.
Genius, genius, genius.
Magic mirror!
Bougie candles.
Ship in a bottle.
I want the magic mirror!
Oh my god.
It's so awesome!
I'm just hoarding money at this point.
I'm gonna do...
Watch the sunset.
I don't think people is...
I don't think we have anyone that's very serious.
Maybe...
Alan?
But we're trying to kick him out.
But he needs more hap...
I think Camel needs the most happiness.
Okay, Camel.
You're watching the sunset.
Camel needs love.
Camel needs self-love.
All right.
Let's end the day.
Money is useless sitting in your pocket?
I'm...
I'm a hoarder, okay?
The self-care task was...
Okay.
Camel is a little happier.
They like the gifts.
Nice.
Camel needs help.
Oh!
Let's see how you did!
Yippee!
Okay.
I don't have enough for any...
Oh!
I can get another action point.
You know what?
We'll take it.
Froggy is redeemable, you guys.
Redemption arc.
There's a chance.
Okay, we're gonna gift the...
We're gonna gift this... gift from Allyn.
It's an apology gift.
Redeemable, redeemable, redeemable.
Oh, see, see, see, see, see, see, see, see, see, see, see!
See, see, see, see, see, see, see, see, see, see, see, see, see, see.
Sweet!
Aren't they gonna talk to each other?
What the heck is this?
A rib cage?
Oh, a fancy big leaf.
He knows you're wanting to kick him out.
We can give another basketball.
Dear diary, I usually look up at the stars, appreciate their beauty, and smile.
But ever since I got the dictionary, I've been thinking about people and smiling too!
These two need to go on a date.
A walk through the park.
Maybe they'll like that.
At least Apollo will like that, right?
Right?
He's so in, boys.
He's so...
We have to gift the basketball.
He has a basketball in his room.
Like, we have to gift the basketball, right?
The plants might be good for Frog, but he likes fancy.
He really likes fancy.
Alright.
Apollo Expedition.
Yeah!
He loved the gift.
He loved it.
Playful.
And let's write an email, and then end the day.
I like how he can kind of make these days go a little bit fast.
Congratulations!
You've won...
an expired coupon for...
unlimited coupons!
Please send money and your DNA.
I love the DNA.
The desire sensor knew what I wanted.
Send your DNA to reserve your prize.
It was almost convincing.
So you almost get a lot of my money.
Romantic painting.
Dead pickle in a jar!
Serious.
Unusual.
Complex.
What's...
A pickle?
Oh, sorry.
In a cage.
Is that how you said this?
My brain just put pickle and jar together, okay?
This is how my brain works.
Okay, you guys.
Jar would have made sense.
Give me that ectoplasm.
No!
But look, it's a top-rated item.
I think we have to buy this.
It'll arrive tomorrow.
Perfect.
Let's see the date, everybody.
Let's see the date.
Oh my gosh.
It's not gonna be awkward.
They like each other too much.
Wow.
The weather is perfect today.
Oh my gosh.
It's a good date.
Is it?
To be honest, I've never really gone out with someone to a park like this before.
Why not?
I think too much about if I'm enjoying things enough or being enjoyable enough.
And then I end up not enjoying anything.
I totally understand.
But you know, you don't have to be that way around me.
Really?
Of course.
When I'm with you, if talking makes you nervous, we can just enjoy silence together.
He's so nice.
This is nice.
It's even nicer being here with you.
Beast Wars is my favorite ship.
Guys, we knocked it out of the park with these two.
The date was good.
The relationship increased.
Yes.
Oh my gosh.
We're gonna get so many.
We're gonna get so much stuff.
What's that?
A little male ghost.
Apollo's taking off.
Oh, the Ip Bay.
I saw that they're talking in there.
Let's go view their conversation.
Oh my gosh.
There's little...
There's little hearts.
Good news, Apollo.
Oh?
I defeated your wrestling friend.
It was easy.
Your friend was waiting in line for some ice cream.
Oh my god.
Beatmo.
Oh.
Beepo ambushed them.
I tackled them and pinned them down.
I refused to let go until they conceded defeat.
Why would you do that?
I'm sorry, Apollo.
But I really do have to go.
I have defeated 1067 other friends now.
I think Beepo is Yandere.
Wait a second.
I think Beepo is Yandere, you guys.
So this might take a while.
Wait.
Oh gosh.
I have to go make 1067 apology calls.
Wait.
1068.
Beepo already defeated one of them.
Oh gosh.
Maybe I should stop Beepo instead.
Is Skynet real?
This is Skynet real.
There's so many paintings around here.
Calm painting.
This isn't a camel...
Bright and artsy.
And sweet.
They mostly like sweet.
Why is your lamp on your bed, you weirdo?
Laundry basket.
Oh wait.
Beepo is practical, right?
Practical.
But Beepo does not wear clothes.
Beepo does not need a laundry basket, I think.
There's so many variations of basketballs in this room.
Dear diary.
I keep thinking about my favorite things about Beepo.
And I can't decide.
I think I like everything.
What does that mean?
Oh my gosh.
I think Apollo is into crazy.
No.
What do you mean?
Beepo wears a hat and a bow tie.
Yeah.
Oh Beepo ruined their diary!
Dear diary.
Did a close study of Apollo recently.
My favorite subject.
What kind of close study are you talking about?
What is...
Is this a glass of water?
You're a tall glass of water.
Nobody else wrote in their diary.
I almost said dictionary.
What is this one?
It's like moving.
Flower wreath.
Full of flowers.
Tool box.
I don't see any of these being good.
A winning apple?
Wait!
There is a real pickle in a cage.
Wait.
This is an alive pickle in a cage.
To go with our dead pickle in the cage.
This one also.
The tall vase is probably good for...
For frog.
Froggy.
Tool box for Beepo.
Hold on.
Let's send an email real quick.
I love the email.
Hi.
This is to confirm your...
Ahem.
Pre-order.
For your...
Crimes?
Oh!
Take it!
No!
The desire sensor.
For your crimes.
Please respond and send money ASAP so we can...
Sell.
It.
I don't read messages.
Okay.
That's fine.
I pre-ordered my crimes.
I like...
Actually...
I told Batara the other day I wanted to do Mad Libs.
Like...
I thought for the...
For the...
Podcast.
But maybe I'll do like a Mad Libs stream one day with someone.
Did I say Batara?
No.
Matara.
Sorry.
My nose is kind of stuffed.
Okay.
Let's try giving...
The laundry basket...
Wait.
Which one has higher?
This one...
They're both practical, aren't they?
Oh, they're both the same.
I think this one's better, though.
It's a little less serious, right?
IX800, thanks for the vibe, gifted!
Neat.
Practical, serious.
I think this one's better, right?
Charging.
And...
Oh.
A dead pickle.
Okay.
From Apollo.
Batara.
See?
Oh my gosh.
It's perfect!
I knew it.
Discovered.
Neat.
Artsy, bright, quiet.
I think this would be good, though.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
I can only...
I can't...
I can...
Steal, but I can't...
I can't do date.
Go cloud gazing.
Lazy, outdoorsy, simple.
Who's unhappy?
Who needs to draw?
Oh.
Froggy's a little unhappy.
Froggy's not very artsy, though.
Or creative.
Okay.
This is for Camel.
A sign.
I will take this, though.
We'll give this to Camel later.
Steal.
Yeah.
Steal and save.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Exactly.
All right.
End the day, baby.
Oh!
It was good!
Good girl!
I am happy!
Good, good, good.
What would be the perfect gift to get the mint?
Anything Metal Gear!
Camel's happier.
What changed?
Actually I can't tell at all.
I like this.
This will be going to Froggy.
Oh.
Never mind.
Noisy unusual dark.
Maybe not.
It's so cool, though.
This can go to Apollo.
Follow... football clock.
See ya.
The sewing machine?
No, that was there from the beginning.
Everything sporty goes to this dude.
From Beepo.
Your favorite yandere.
Spank!
Thanks for the 20 gift cards!
Thank you!
Yep, yep, yep!
I knew it.
I knew it, I knew it, I knew it.
What's here?
How do I get more residents?
Oh!
I want to matchmake more residents.
But I don't want to get rid of any of my ones that I've already got.
Check out upgrades in Ghostina's shop.
Ah!
Upgrade the manor, you'll get more rooms and more residents.
There are a lot of good upgrades in the shop.
Has anyone noticed Ghostina told us there was monies and shops in the afterlife and we just accepted it?
Seriously?
Has anyone found anywhere else they can spend those relationships?
Off topic post here.
Thread closed by modern.
I think Ghostina is the moderator.
Probably.
When is she coming back?
Historical painting.
Maybe he would like this.
Okay, hold on.
Let's try and make him...
We're gonna do this.
Okay.
This is for Beepo.
Go to a farmer's market.
Okay, hold on.
They might actually like this.
Okay, you guys.
You guys, this might be good.
And then, you know what?
You, Apollo, just go do your thing.
Actually, no.
No one.
We'll only do the two.
That's fine.
Okay, there we go.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, now let's send an email.
Hello, I am...
a ghost.
Your grandmother.
And I need your help with...
Money, money, money, money.
Charity.
To help...
your butt.
The planet.
Please, I need your help.
Grandma!
Yes, let's do it!
Recently, I keep getting these, like, emails in my business email that are like...
I don't even know...
Grandma!
Oh my god, stop.
Stop!
It's too much!
Please buy yourself anything Metal Gear related with this as a gift if you wanna otherwise use it on whatever!
No!
But thank you, but no!
It's way too much, thank you though, but no!
Please!
Don't worry about it.
I worry about it!
Oh my gosh.
I don't...
First of all, don't enable...
Okay.
Did anybody see that...
That...
That statue?
The...
The one of the...
Of...
Big Boss, like, saluting at the grave?
I'll be honest.
I didn't think about it.
But...
I don't know.
I don't wanna be...
It's also...
First of all, it's huge, so I don't think I have any, like...
I don't think I have anywhere to put it.
And also...
Um...
I don't know.
I'm like, do I wanna be reminded of this sadness every single day?
Yeah, I tagged you.
I know, tons of people tagged me.
Isn't it like $500 for the full one?
It is.
Yeah, it's quite expensive.
It's quite pricey.
It would probably be the most...
If I were to buy it, it would be the most expensive figure I'd ever bought ever.
But...
When I first saw it, the replies had you and Maddie immediately tagged.
I'm more surprised you didn't pre-order it already.
Well, it's $500.
It's $500.
You know, I...
I'm not just...
You know...
Even...
I...
I am...
I am careful with money.
Contrary to popular belief.
You know, I...
I'm careful with money.
But...
Gosh...
I don't know.
Like I said, it's really big too.
I thought...
I don't know.
Not much, but this is my big Boss Funds contribution nation.
Thank you so much!
$500 for 1 fourth scale isn't even that much compared to some anime figures.
That is so true.
That is very true.
That is very, very true.
But also, I can play that, you know?
It's like buying a quarter of it.
It's a console, basically.
For one game.
Everybody who bought the PS5.
Me too.
For DULT!
Go to the world!
Enabling only if you have the space!
Doing my part for the boss, thank you.
It's way too much.
It's way too much, please.
Oh gosh.
This is me.
This is me right now.
It's cool if you don't get it.
Stop!
I just think it's so much.
And you said so much.
Oh my gosh.
To himself.
Thanks for the gift.
I mean, not gifted.
Thanks for the donut.
Thank you super chat.
Thank you so much.
Even the chat AI thinks he already bought it.
Oh my gosh.
Let's end the day.
Later that day.
Okay.
This is their first non-awkward date, everybody.
This is their first...
Thanks for coming to this market with me.
I'm so excited.
Of course.
But to be honest, I haven't been to this one before.
Oh.
Let me show you around.
It can get pretty crowded, so take my hand.
Froggy here with the smooth moves.
What?
Okay.
Phew.
We made it through those crowds.
Um, Camel.
You're still holding my hand.
Oh.
I'm sorry.
I just...
It's okay.
We should keep holding hands!
Yeah.
In case any crowds pop up again.
Right.
Just in case.
Baby incoming.
Don't say that!
What kind of creature?
This is the future of evolution.
The Riz!
Oh my gosh.
Chat, we are so back.
The date was good!
I think it was better than good.
House helper task was good!
Beeple's relationships with all other residents increased.
Alan just saved himself from becoming Niner.
It's true.
What a good day.
What a good day, everybody.
Let's see how you did!
Oh, it's 37!
You guys, we killed it.
We killed it.
We can get hats now.
Or the spooky song.
Scary song or hats.
Ene, mene, mene, mo, che ito, Apollo by it's toe, if it hollers let em go.
My mom said to pick the very best one.
One, and you are it!
We're getting hats!
Confirm.
We got hats, everybody!
Apollo's happier.
There's some cheese on the ground!
The manor upgraded!
Check out the new wardrobe.
Oh my gosh, I'm a little devil.
I'm a little devil.
Oh, so cute!
Oh, I can't unlock this one yet.
Which one do we have?
The ribbon is really cute!
This one's so cute.
I like the devil one too, though.
Or the beret.
Okay, we'll go with the ribbon.
Wait, but if I do a blue ribbon, it matches me!
Actually!
Blue ribbon is just like Minto!
Yeah!
Oh my gosh!
It looks just like me!
Oh my gosh, it looks just like me!
Is that a can of beans?
Oh, paint bucket.
Ouch!
I hit my knee on the table.
Did you guys hear that?
Oh...
Where?
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh god.
I'm okay.
Oh my gosh!
She's got little decorations and everything!
It's your diary.
People gifted me a football clock.
I'm adding this to my favorite things I've ever gotten list.
Because it's from one of my favorite people at the moment.
Okay, why'd you have to say it like that?
Why can't people just be your favorite person?
Breadsticks!
Bag...
Get...
Bask...
Bag...
Basket of baguettes!
Wee!
I cannot say that for some reason.
I cannot say it.
What is this thing?
Hot air balloon lamp.
Adventurous and bright.
None of these really fit everybody here.
Maybe the artsy?
Creative?
It's like they're talking.
French wisps.
Where you at?
I know you're out there.
Say that five times really fast.
I can barely say it even once!
Bag...
Bags...
Bask...
Basket of baguettes.
I can barely even say it once...
I cannot say this word.
Let's see...
Let's check the Internet...
See if there's anything here that...
The Ghost pepper...
Ghost plush!
Artsy Classical...
Classic musical...
None of these really fit, huh?
Oh!
The calm painting!
Let's go give this to...
Um, you.
Camel.
From Froggy.
Gift.
Check it out, check it out, check it out, check it out.
I guess we don't always have to do gifts.
Because not always though.
Love, love, love, love, love!
Oh my gosh.
Enough love to have a conversation about it?
We're here?
Camel.
Oh.
Olin.
Listen, I'm so sorry.
Here is your payment.
What?
Whoa, this is very generous.
But I thought you hated...
I did.
But I am no monster.
You are a very talented seamstress after all.
You still deserve recognition and compensation.
Oh, the redemption reel.
Goodbye.
Oh.
Olin, wait!
Yes?
Listen, please.
I'm so, so sorry.
I had my head stuck in this cosplay world.
And I just assumed you meant wizard robes.
I think Camel was looking for something else.
I really should have taken my client into consideration.
And I should have known you meant ceremonial robes.
Or I should have at least clarified with you.
Yes, that's what's foolish of you to assume.
What?
Clarify, Froggy!
Shut the hell up!
Please accept my apology.
You were my first customer.
And I'm still learning how to do all of this.
Very well.
And as long as we're apologizing, I suppose I could have discussed details with you further as well.
And I could have been more courteous about it.
Yeah, exactly.
Oh.
Would you please accept my apology, Camel?
Oh, of course.
Thank you.
Okay.
And all is well.
All is well that ends well.
Oh my gosh.
Let's send an email.
Let's go scam some people.
Love is in the air.
Hi.
I couldn't help but notice...
You're a ghost!
And we have...
Oh, a heist!
That!
Oh no!
Straight up isn't working!
I messed it up!
I messed it up big time!
If you are interested, send money now to reserve your position.
There was a podcast in there?
I'm not convinced.
But here's a little something.
Hey, pity money.
They're talking.
They're hanging out.
Okay, now let's do...
Ride a tandem bicycle.
Apollo and...
Beepo.
Oh my gosh, they're almost maxed!
Oh my gosh, Camel.
Oh my gosh, this fits every single person here!
This is perfect!
Podcast was one of the responses.
This game scares me a little bit, you guys.
This game scares me.
It's a little on the nose sometimes, I think.
Beepo has no legs.
Wear a hat!
While watching a date.
Hold on, I'm eating my croissant.
I'm eating my croissant.
I almost choked on my croissant.
I'm okay.
This is amazing.
Yeah, you're pretty good at this.
You mean we're pretty good at this.
I'm doing great.
And on this tandem bike, we'll be unstoppable!
What was that evil cackle for?
Because I'm going to take us to all the most fun and exciting places I can think of!
Because I want to share my favorite things with you.
If you're okay with that.
Well, as long as it's with you.
I think that sounds great.
Perfect.
Let's get pedaling!
Apollo likes I'm freaky, you guys.
Did Apollo manage to stop Beeple from beating all his friends?
I don't think so.
I think Beeple has killed them at this point.
It's almost... there's like a tiny sliver.
The tiniest sliver.
Camel happier.
Froggy, good.
Yes!
What happens at five hearts?
I don't know!
And I'm scared!
I'm scared.
Camel is happier.
Oh, Camel.
Sorry.
Wow!
So cute!
This dude... Froggy has nothing in his room.
I got the ghost plushie.
I think this would be good for Froggy.
Yeah, steal that.
We'll just give that right away.
I think we haven't done a lot for Froggy, so he probably is unhappy.
He's like, this is unfair.
I'm being treated.
I'm being treated wrongly in this place.
There was nothing in your room, Jack.
Hahaha!
Oh my gosh.
The slowest walker ever in existence.
Yeah!
Big love!
Discovered a clear sick.
Perfect.
Oh!
They're dying.
Oh my gosh.
You'll never believe what happened.
I was considering locking myself up in my room forever.
Oh my gosh.
Such a mood.
But all unapologized about the robes.
I guess next time I should clarify what the request is.
Lesson learned.
Does Froggy know what day it is?
I have no idea.
Popcorn machine!
That's pretty fun.
Even up here looks fancy, right?
Even the attic looks nicer.
Family portrait... of... of... rowboats?
This one I think would also be good for Froggy, huh?
I think, yeah.
It's a family portrait of canoes.
Maybe it's good.
Perfume tray.
Interesting.
Fancy and fashionable.
Fancy!
Okay, we're giving you two things.
It's your lucky day, man.
It's your lucky day.
Grandpa and grandma...
Oh my god, he loves it!
This is so silly.
That's some love love going on right there.
Look, there's hearts coming out from their heads.
Let's go... love is in the air and so is scamming people.
Scam!
Are you tired of...
...things?
You could be earning a million coins every week if you became...
...interesting.
If you're interested, please send...
Oh, shoot.
Your favorite TV show.
Dang it.
Earn a million coins a week!
Oh my gosh, we're girlbossing.
First time scamming?
Gold match those shapes better, pal.
I was only off one!
Gosh.
Tough crowd.
Cactus plush.
Arcade machine is so awesome.
I'm gonna buy it.
Order.
We'll just hold on to it, right?
What's in our... wait.
What's in our inventory?
No, no, no.
Oh, wait.
Yeah, let's end the day.
What's in our inventory?
Okay, wait.
Oh, here.
We have the pickle.
And we have the ghost.
Relationships.
Wow.
All he cares is for people.
He's committed.
Eyes for no other.
Eyes for literally no other.
Wow!
Looks like some of your residents are ready to move on to the next phase of their life!
Don't worry.
They're not gonna become ghosts.
That's the next phase of their life.
Whenever residents reach max relationship level or max happiness, you can watch their final relationship talk or read their final diary entry at the end of the day.
However, keep in mind that they'll also move out of the manor tomorrow if we decide to do so.
Well, it might seem sad to see them go.
You should know that you helped them find a happier life.
Plus, this lets more residents move in.
Until we run out of residents.
You don't have to make a decision right now, either.
You can move them out when you're ready.
The Apollo Expedition...
is ready to launch.
Wait, I thought it was Apollo!
It's all in Ed Campbell!
I'm so sorry.
I was so prepared for people and...
Apollo to leave.
But it wasn't even them!
I'm so sorry!
OK.
We'll be doing this final relationship talk.
We'll commit this bear.
And they will move out of the manor.
Are you sure you want to proceed?
Wait, wait, wait, I'm not ready yet.
I want to see it.
I want to see Froggy's room.
I just gave you all that stuff.
10 out of 10 plot twists.
That was crazy.
Wait until tomorrow?
Yeah, we'll wait.
Are you finished with moving out?
Yeah, yeah, go for it.
Day 12.
Hi Mintel, is it probably the anxiety voice in my head talking?
I hope us fans who really like your chemistry with streamers you've collabed with don't weird you out so much that it makes you not want to collab with them.
We can always tone it down.
No, I've never felt that way.
Don't worry about it.
Usually if I'm not collabing with someone it's... Whoa!
Holy fancy!
If I'm not collabing with someone it's usually a schedule thing.
Oh my gosh, fancy room.
Okay, thank you.
Yeah!
What is this?
Oh, it's a box!
It's a cardboard box!
Love ghostie?
I sure do!
That one's for me.
Look at that giant burger!
Really big burger.
Sorry, it's a really big burger, not a giant burger.
Fast food that slows you down.
Actually, thinking about that kind of is making me feel a little...
Dear diary, do you ever feel like other people's happiness is how you measure your own happiness?
What am I supposed to do when there's no one else to make happy though?
What do you mean by that?
They're in love love.
Where, where?
Oh, there you go.
Where's your diary?
Oh, right here.
Is that a Metal Gear reference?
No.
Maybe.
Fries!
Wait, we have burger and fries.
That's crazy.
A cute clock.
Well, I'm not going to give you guys anything else because you're leaving.
You're literally moving out.
Why would I give you anything?
A lost painting.
Mysterious talisman.
Fun.
Moving out present.
It's a waste of my activity points.
What if I send like two of them on a date?
What if I send like Beepo and Froggy on a date?
Visit a science museum!
Wait a second.
This is literally perfect for them.
This is perfect for them.
This is not what Allyn likes to do, but your last, your last thing that you do in this household is you wash the windows, Froggy Prince.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, Camel's going to become a, become royalty.
Maybe.
Okay.
Let's send a scam email.
Hello.
There has been a massive security breach today.
In order to...
Not delete your butt.
Why is there so much about the butt?
Your business.
Please send money and your...
Address.
To us immediately.
I can't lose my scamming business.
Take my coins now!
Uh, you did not send your address.
Get...
Get hacked.
Okay.
Let's end the day.
Here we go, everybody.
Here we go.
A science museum chore?
No way!
I love science museums!
Me too.
I love those self-guided audio tours and walking around.
I love running around and learning!
Woo!
Yippee!
Oh no, they're out of audio tour tapes.
Oh no.
I have an idea.
Why don't I read out everything for you?
You can go through the exhibits without reading and enjoy them with just your eyes.
What?
No.
I couldn't ask you to do that.
There are a lot of signs here.
Nonsense.
I love reading out loud.
Let me put on my narrator voice.
You guys are so lucky.
You guys are so lucky I'm not on my normal computer.
You guys are so lucky I'm not on my normal computer to use the narrator voice.
I would...
If I had time, literally, I would download the voice mod right now.
And I would... I would do it.
Ahem.
Welcome to our award-winning audio tour.
This is a special tour just for Beep-o.
Beep-o.
Beep
-o.
Beep -o.
Beep-o.
Please keep all hands inside the vehicle at all times.
What vehicle?
Please save all questions until after the tour.
This is better than any audio tour I could have imagined.
Thank you, Apollo.
She's really into that.
She loves AI voice.
Robots, after all, you know.
Why can you do the laugh so well?
Because I'm obsessed.
Maxed.
Everybody's going to leave, you guys.
We're going to get four whole new residents.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
Goodbye, everyone.
Everybody, goodbye.
Tiger cyber.
And whatever this cursed couple is.
Cam, I have something to show you.
Oh my gosh.
It's a photo of you in the wizard robes.
Now that's a little sensual.
Well, yes.
They are beautifully made, after all.
Shouldn't go to waste.
It's you in only the wizard robes.
They're also very comfortable.
Oh my gosh, Alan.
I'm so glad you wore them.
What do you have there, Camel?
Oh, well, I ended up making the original request.
Oh my goodness.
Are these my ceremonial robes?
Yes.
And, um, I...
My eyes cannot begin to understand the beauty.
Um.
That I have just been presented with.
Is this happening?
Yes.
Camel.
This is single-handedly the most beautiful piece of wardrobe I have ever seen.
To say this is no easy feat.
Oh.
Oh wow.
This settles it.
You are officially in charge of all my clothing.
Oh.
This is a... This is some kind of relationship.
I think.
What?
Yes, yes.
Please do not hesitate.
No one can ever compare to you for this role.
Do you really mean it?
No one's ever loved my work this much.
A business relationship.
Yeah.
Then they are fools.
Everything you do is a masterpiece.
Because I can see you put your heart into it.
Oh, imagine what everyone will think when I put this on.
Come, Camel.
We have much to do.
Quick, quick.
Oh gosh.
What have I gotten myself into?
But I'm honored.
That's it?
They're so small together.
I just realized.
Look how small they are.
He didn't get a partner.
He got a tailor.
There we go.
Everybody's moving out, you guys.
Literally, so no .
But didn't they confess?
The manga?
Oh my gosh.
Sorry, the TV has some unadon.
Looks delicious.
Unadon.
It's summer but I still haven't had any unagi yet.
It's summer but I still haven't had any unagi.
I haven't eaten yet.
It looks so good.
Oh my god.
Oh.
No.
It looks so good.
Sorry, okay.
I'm not looking at the TV anymore.
Still time once your stomach settles down.
Yeah, I have a little bit of time.
People.
You have to stop this.
Oh no.
Am I not your best friend anymore, Apollo?
No, you are.
Why are you trying to defeat all my other friends?
Well, being your best friend felt like a lot of responsibility.
I'm so excited to be your best friend, but I don't know if I'm good enough.
So I have to defeat all your other friends to be sure that I am the best.
Little people.
Friendship?
Wait.
So first we have a business relationship and then this is...
This does not feel very romantic.
Friendship isn't a competition?
And to be honest...
Oh!
To be honest, I was hoping that our friendship would bloom into something more than just friends.
Really?
That's what I was hoping for too.
Well then, maybe we should cool off on the whole defeating all of my friends thing.
And focus more on the more than friends thing.
Yes, I would much rather focus my attention on that.
And after that, we can be the best couple.
Does that mean we have to defeat the other couples?
Yes, I already have plans for how we can do that.
Beepo... Beepo is starting a war.
Let's go.
Oh no!
I was kidding!
Beepo!
Come back!
Go Beepo!
Kill them all!
Would you like to view their diaries for the last time?
Yeah, I guess we'll see everybody.
Oh wait.
Oh, we saw that one.
We read that one.
And we read that one.
We're good.
Okay.
We didn't even write anything!
Beepo is starting a war to prove that love can bloom on the battlefield.
Let's see how you did!
53 guys!
Let's go.
More hats?
Am I hearing more hats everybody?
But I really want the scary song.
I'm so close to being able to get both.
Let's do the song this time.
And we'll save for the hats.
A resident's arriving.
Wait, I don't get to choose!
Oh gosh, who's coming in?
A drone?
More robots!
Yeah!
Cute!
I'm here!
A resident is arriving.
Oh.
Oh!
Wow!
Oh gosh!
It's Noir!
Oh my gosh!
They left their little plushie of themselves!
So sweet!
Check the memories.
Oh.
Hello?
Sing a song.
Congrats.
Now you can make ghost noises.
Well, I guess you always made that whoosh sound.
But now you can sing songs for your residents!
Let's start with a scary song.
If you sing the song near a resident, it will scare them.
But that's not always a bad thing.
For instance, if you see two residents in a room.
They were where they were.
Together.
And you want them to stop talking to each other.
Oh.
Use this song.
It doesn't take any actions.
So feel free to sing it as much as you want.
You need at least one resident in the room for this song to take effect.
Okay.
Wait.
Can I sing anything then?
What else can I sing?
Um.
Okay.
I think you can do it.
Try it.
Okay.
I think you can do it.
Oh.
It could be...
You can do it.
I think you can do it.
No.
Okay.
I think you can do it.
Yeah.
All right.
So you're probably gonna have a good idea of...
Yeah, sure.
Sure.
Which one is that again?
Bad apple.
Left, right, up.
How does it go though?
You guys wouldn't be able to tell me, huh?
Oh no!
I was gonna scare them!
Oh my gosh, look at the chocolate... charcoal flavor.
I should have known you could play the Therament.
What's the one...
I'll be honest you guys, I never actually played Ocarina of Time.
Because I never had an N64.
Rock celery.
I never had one.
I had a friend that I watched play a little bit.
Aw, aren't Beepo and Apollo so cute?
I miss them already.
Oh, did you see what they left on the memories board?
Oh, wait, they actually left something on the memories board?
This?
Oh, I have a relationship!
Apple hog!
The couples to defeat.
The couple across the street.
The couples that keep saying how cute they are.
Beepo, what is this list?
It's the 3DS remake queen.
I know!
But that like came out so long ago after, you know?
Casey!
Thanks for the gift!
Don't worry Apollo.
I have analyzed their weaknesses and I'm confident we can defeat them.
Do we have to defeat them?
Can't we just go out with them instead?
Apollo?
Apollo doesn't just want to be friends with everybody.
He also wants to be couples with everybody.
Couples to double date with.
Every couple.
Resulting in a higher number of dates with Apollo.
Oh, I like that list a lot better.
Number 1!
Wait, they're so cute.
They're so cute.
And then there was the other one.
The apple hog.
Dearest Campbell.
Oh, sorry.
Urgent news.
I need the nicest outfit you can whip up.
Need it tonight?
Thanks.
Olin, please.
Olin.
Wait, for tonight?
I don't know if I can work that quickly.
How fancy are we talking here?
Dearest Campbell.
Very fancy.
It's a very important occasion.
What?
What occasion?
I don't have it on my calendar.
I have all of your events on my calendar.
Dearest Campbell.
A dinner with you.
Oh, okay.
Okay, right on that.
Is it a vampire outfit?
It's so cute.
They're a cosplay queen.
They're matching even.
This is so cute.
Oh my gosh.
Let's see how Noir is.
Dear diary.
This house is about to become a whole lot more fashionable.
I already have some ideas for how to make this place fabulous.
Oh la la.
What about you?
Ami.
Dear diary.
I'm so excited.
My room has so much space for wild experiments.
Well, almost.
Maybe my roommates won't mind me taking up a tad bit more room.
Dear diary.
I'm so excited.
My room has so much space for wild experiments.
Well, almost.
Maybe my roommates won't mind me taking up a tad bit more room.
What is this?
Cup ramen?
Literal instant noodles.
Wowee.
Well, let's see what debt it is.
What's your favorite song to sing to your residents?
What the title says.
Scary song.
Because they look so funny when they're scared.
They'll even run away from the room they're in.
The romantic song is cute.
But it only works if you have two residents in the same room.
The happy song is nice.
It works on both residents if you sing it to two residents in the same room too.
I like using the scary song to stop residents from talking to each other.
I like using the scary song to send residents to the kitchen to talk to each other.
Obviously the money song.
It's free money.
Wait, so you can sing infinitely then?
You can, but it gets less effective the more you use it.
It'll go back to full effectiveness the next day.
There's a money song!
Oh yeah.
My first couple just moved out.
OMG I match-maked?
Match made?
My first couple?
And they just moved out together?
I miss them already.
Congrats!
It's always so sweet.
And there are so many more relationships out there to make.
You made them happy.
So happy.
Nice job.
I cried for ten days after my first couple left.
Did they leave any presents for the manor?
My residents left me cute plushies of themselves.
Make sure to check the memories board.
And the kitchen after they move out.
I can rewatch their whole relationship.
Oh god.
Now I'm gonna go cry for ten more days.
My- oh.
The conspiracy theory!
They're back!
My theory.
Part one.
Have you ever thought about how weird it is that we are ghost matchmakers?
And for what?
What if we are in a simulation?
Lol.
That's so random.
You really think we're in a simulation?
Like someone created this world?
Right?
Even if someone could make this world?
Why would they make this and not something cooler?
Huh.
I never thought about that.
Hey, at Conspiracy Theory.
Please keep the forums on topic.
This is not a place for your theories.
Ghosts are haters?
Yeah, there's so many thumbs down on all these perfectly normal responses.
Well, this person is not contributing to the conversation.
A simple ghost.
They're just... they're just... you know...
Chemistry side.
Record player...
Let's send an email.
Hello.
If you like...
Uh oh.
Streaming?
Games.
We've launched a new...
Oh.
Streaming platform.
That...
Uh...
Has infinite storage space.
If you like early access, please send us money to join the waiting list.
Good eep mail message.
It almost made sense.
Awesome.
So I'm guessing we'll get two more people tomorrow?
Oh, wait, I can sing the song.
I want to scare them.
Combo breaker.
I'm gonna gift this.
Wait, maybe I shouldn't gift anything yet until we get all new people, right?
I don't know.
There might be, like, the perfect match.
Or they could be the perfect match for each other.
I don't know.
I don't know anything.
Okay.
Small guy, big goth girl.
Wait, hold on.
Small Ami and big goth Mami.
She's a sheep who never follows the herd.
She aspires to be the very first flying hamster.
Oh, she's a hamster!
She's very solution-oriented.
Moved out with Olin.
Wait, what do you mean the current happiness is, like...
Wait.
Beeple, are you okay?
Beeple, what happened to you?
What's your happiness?
Hamster song.
I'm just gonna keep sending emails today, I think.
Wait, what's this?
A lucky penny?
D to die.
Oh.
Okay, ready?
Hot chocolate.
All these are not so great gifts either.
Oh wait, but they can do chores at least.
Eat a snack.
Wait, buy a new rug.
This is so noir.
Fancy and fashionable.
And then Ami can do this.
Okay.
A sign.
And then let's go do some more emails.
Blank has been posted on blank.
Oh my gosh, a butt?
A computer virus?
A transaction?
A big ol' bill?
An appropriate message!
You guys, this is scary.
This is a scary one.
I want a butt so bad.
Yeah!
A butt has been posted on...
Your butt!
If you want this removed, please reply with monies and...
Gold!
Yes, save me.
No!
Not my butt!
Oh my god!
New people!
New people come in!
It was okay.
But this one was good.
Yeah, yeah.
Fancy and fashionable.
Okay.
Not my butt.
New people!
A resident is arriving!
Who is this?
It's...
Elephant!
Oh no!
They're dumb!
Felix!
A resident has arrived!
Penguin!
Okay, I guess...
It's Wobbles!
Wobbles loves...
Wow.
Fancy.
Fountain.
Oh my gosh, they're all so cute.
No, no!
Dear diary.
Hi!
It's a new journal.
So excited to meet everyone and...
Oops.
Great.
I spilled tomato sauce all over the first page.
Sorry, diary.
It's okay.
I guess even penguins eat spaghetti.
What about you, Felix?
It's your diary.
Found this empty book in my room.
Who buys empty books?
Weird.
Well, I'm gonna write in it and finish it for them.
I bet Wobbles will love that snowman.
I agree!
What is this, though?
A xylophone.
A woodblock.
Probably named by the same person who named the triangle.
Noot!
Oh!
Some fancy tea!
Okay.
Well, guys.
I think I might actually end it here.
Because...
I am feeling a little...
Oof.
Um...
I'm gonna go...
Grab some...
I actually have medicine.
It's like a drinkable medicine.
I have to put it in, um...
In the water.
So...
Um...
Yeah!
Thank you guys for watching and hanging out with me.
And this is so much fun.
It's so cute.
Um...
And...
Yeah!
Almost three hours.
Oh!
You're so right!
Yeah!
Almost three hours.
For real.
So...
Hmm.
Thank you guys!
This is such a cute and silly game.
Um...
I had a lot of fun with it.
Of course...
You know...
I feel most in my element when I'm a ghost.
And...
Um...
I've never done matchmaking before.
But...
Maybe...
I really have a knack for it.
I think...
I...
Maybe...
Um...
Like...
I'm a real professional.
Probably.
But thank you guys!
Thanks for hanging out with me!
Thank you for all the donuts and super chats!
Cute game.
Thanks for the stream.
Thanks make me!
Thank you guys so much.
Really, really, really appreciate it.
Chuu!
Such a cute game.
I hope you can stream it...
So...
Somewhere...
When you want something chill.
Yeah!
Thank you.
Very fun little game.
Thank you, Minto.
Thank you!
Yeah!
We have so much...
Um...
I wish we could see the shop.
Hold on.
Let's see...
Was it...
Was it under eye here?
I wish there was a way to see like the tree.
You know?
So that I could see what things we still needed to unlock.
But...
Um...
There was a lot...
To unlock still.
So...
Hmm!
Um...
Do you have any tips for Wisp to Wisp love?
Hmm...
Higher...
Higher than...
Wow!
This time, thanks to the five gifted!
Will you be streaming tomorrow?
No!
I will be putting out my schedule like...
Very soon.
Like probably...
Maybe like right after this.
Um...
But I won't be streaming tomorrow.
So...
Yeah.
Looking forward to whatever ships you craft next.
Both in game and IRL.
I...
IRL?
Ashes?
Try Princess?
Thank you!
Hi...
How much does a Wisp cost?
Oh...
I mean...
You hire them...
You could say...
Um...
Hire them to like...
Rub your feet...
Hire them to...
Um...
Hire them...
Hire someone to stand next to your hot water boiler and press the button to turn it on whenever you need the hot water?
Tuna?
Wait...
What is Tuna doing?
What did Tuna do?
Wait...
You guys...
I...
Tuna sites?
Oh...
Tuna...
Tuna sites?
I know Tuna sites...
Yeah...
The ship...
The Tuna Maple ship name...
I know...
I have a sticker...
Of them...
Oimo gave it to me...
Wait...
Yeah...
I think...
Well...
I got...
Actually...
A couple people...
I have like a couple of them...
Because several of them...
I think Lily gave me one too...
Several people gave me some...
Ofcai...
There is even merch...
Of...
Oh my gosh...
Wait...
So I really am...
A professional at this...
Because of Tuna sites...
I am a professional matchmaker!
Oh...
Sorry, that was my mic...
I punched it out of excitement...
Yeah...
Tuna...
Mr. Fish...
Welcome to the MamboShop...
Thank you...
I am an expert...
I am a genius...
I am a...
I am a real professional...
Yippee!
Hahaha...
Okay...
I am going to go now guys...
I do not know what that means...
But happy nonetheless...
Do not even...
Worry about it...
Do not forget nanoboys...
Nanoboys...
Wait, that's the first time I heard that one.
It's a real one.
Really?
Help?
Are you guys actually...
It's real?
Wait, it's real real?
Oh no.
Oh wait.
Nanoboy is real.
I don't understand this.
People... just people in the chat shipping each other.
Don't worry about it.
Real.
It's real?
Are you guys actually...
It's real.
They're... wait, they're divorced.
When I get you...
I'm leaving.
You guys go do your own weird things in the Discord, okay?
No.
Okay.
Thanks guys.
Thank you.
Bye bye.
Suddenly see more.
Also Pirate5.
Pirate5, I see you.
Guess you're super natural at this.
Get out of here.